the Nights Watch don't care if you live
or die
mance rayder don't care if I live or die
we're just soldiers in their armies and
there's plenty more to carry on if we go
down
it's you and me that matters to me
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in A
Song of Ice and Fire Theory video today
I'm gonna need everyone to put on your
tinfoil hats because I want to discuss a
semi crazy theory about Jon Snow and
Ygritte before I go any further there
are a few things I want to say first I
think the chances of this theory being
true are very slim and even if it is
true I doubt we will ever find out
anyway but I haven't heard anyone talk
about this before which is why I
ultimately decided to make a video about
it I also need to say that I actually
didn't think of this on my own like I've
told you in some of my recent
foreshadowing videos I had been watching
Game of Thrones with one of my friends
who has never seen the series before I
have tried to watch as many episodes
with him as possible that way I could
help explain a few things to him that
might make his first watch a little
easier to digest well about two weeks
ago I was over his house watching a few
episodes with him and during one of
these episodes he said something that I
had never considered and after thinking
about it for a while I thought I should
make a video about it because I found
myself wondering if it could have
possibly been true and I wanted to get
your input on this idea the only problem
is the theory is irrelevant now because
it never ended up having any impact on
the story but I want to talk about it
anyway because it's kind of hard to
disprove at the same time so let's begin
the scene I am referring to takes place
in season 4 episode 8 and this is when
the wildlings attack moles town which is
right outside of Castle black in this
scene we can see the wildlings
butchering everyone in sight as they
make their way closer to Castle black in
the middle of this slaughter there is a
moment where we see Ygritte killing some
people inside of the hut and at the time
Gilly is hiding with baby Sam
after yeegar it kills one of the
prostitutes she hears Gilley's baby cry
which leads her to discovering where
they are hiding this is when Jaeger
looks at them for a few moments then she
decides she is not going to kill them so
she motions for them to be quiet
so someone else doesn't come along and
butcher them it was at this moment that
my friend looks over at me and he says
yogurt is pregnant he thought that was
why she allow
Gilly and her baby to live when he said
this I didn't even say anything in
response I just kind of sit there and
thought about it for a while because I
had never entertained the idea of yogurt
being pregnant with John's baby at least
in the television show there isn't much
evidence to back this up we know John
and Ygritte were having unprotected sex
but that doesn't always lead to a
pregnancy and unfortunately the eager it
ends up dying before we could ever find
out if this was true or not but I
started to think about John and egrets
relationship in the books and this led
me to reading some of John's chapters
again I wanted to see if there was any
more evidence to support this idea and I
did find a few things although they
aren't as solid as I would have hoped
let's take a look at a few quotes from
the books in a Storm of Swords torment
and John are having a conversation about
his relationship with Ygritte and this
is what was said do you miss like the
girl torment asked him as they pass
another 20 Mammoth's these bearing
wildlings in tall wooden towers instead
of giants no but I what can I say that
he will believe I am still too young to
Wed Wed torment laughed who spoke of
wedding in the South must a man Wed
every girl he beds John could feel
himself turning red again she spoke for
me when Rattleshirt would have killed me
I would not dishonor her you are a free
man now in Ygritte as a free woman
what dishonor if he laid together I
might get her what child a I'd hope so
a strong son or a lively laughing girl
kissed by fire and where's the harm in
that words failed him for a moment the
boy the child would be a bastard or
bastards weaker than other children more
sickly more like to fail no but your
bastard born yourself and if he Girt
does not want a child she will go to
some woods witch and drink a cup of moon
tea you do not come into it once the
seed is planted
I will not father a bastard so as you
can see the thought of John getting
eager pregnant has been discussed before
by John himself now they certainly
doesn't mean John got her pregnant when
they had sex but it could be seen as
foreshadowing that John will one day
become a father
although tormund did say that if Jaeger
did not want to have a child she would
go to some woods which and drink a cup
of moon tea to get rid of the baby
perhaps this is something you Gert had
done before she even met John however
something tells me if John did happen to
get eager pregnant she would not have
wanted to get an abortion with John's
child considering how much she really
liked him she might have wanted to keep
it now in the television show we only
see John and ye Gert have sex one time
which was in the cave but in the books
the text does suggest that they have sex
many times let's take a look at another
quote from one of John's chapters at
this point in the books John and eager
to have already had sex so this takes
place after their first time laying
together and this is what John was
thinking they shared the same sleeping
skins every night and he went to sleep
with her head against his chest and her
red hair tickling his chin the smell of
her had become a part of him her crooked
teeth and the feel of her breasts when
he cupped it in his hand
and the taste of her mouth they were his
joy and his despair many a night he lay
with the eager and warm beside him
wondering if his Lord Father had felt
this confused about his mother whoever
she had been it sounds like John and
Ygritte were having sex pretty much
every night now this also doesn't mean
she was pregnant but if they were
constantly having unprotected sex this
would definitely increase her chances of
becoming pregnant there is something
else from the books that I want to show
you and this happens when John is
dreaming and his dream may be
foreshadowing a few different things in
a Storm of Swords after he great fills
John full of arrows he makes it back to
Castle black but he is badly injured
when John arrives they give him some
milk of the poppy
and this is what happens drink this
Grenn held a cup to his lips
John drank his head was full of wolves
and eagles the sound of his brothers
laughter the faces above him began to
blur and fade they can't be dead Theon
would never do that
in Winterfell grey granite oak and iron
crows wailing around the towers steam
rising off the hot pools and the gods
would the stone came sitting on
Thrones how could Winterfell be gone
when the dreams took him he found
himself back home once more splashing in
the hot pools beneath a huge white where
would that had his father's face eager
it was with him laughing at him shedding
her skins till she was naked as her name
day trying to kiss him but he couldn't
not what this father watching
he was the blood of Winterfell a man of
the Nights Watch
I will not father a bastard he told her
I will not I will not you know nothing
Jon Snow
she whispered her skin dissolving into
hot water the flesh beneath sloughing
off her bones until only skull and
skeleton remained in the pool bubbled
thicken read okay now there are a few
different ways you can look at this
dream since we're talking about the
possibility of yeegar being pregnant
let's start there first
during this dream John is in Winterfell
and he is in the hot pools beneath the
weirwood tree in the godswood as he is
in the water he sees Ygritte and she
gets naked she tries to kiss Jon but he
doesn't want to do it what this father
watching plus he is a man of the Nights
Watch and he is worried about getting
Nygaard pregnant John does not want a
father a bastard and not just because of
his Night's Watch of fouls but also
because John has a bastard himself and
he does not want to have a son that
would have to grow up being treated the
same way as him so what's up there in
the brothel as ROS took off her clothes
but I couldn't do it because all I could
think was what if I got her pregnant she
had a child another bastard named snow
it's a good life for a child this is
something that John is always thinking
about and it's even haunting him in his
dreams in this dream he tells Ygritte
I will not father a bastard I will not I
will not
but then he Girt says you know nothing
Jon Snow
now what does Ygritte mean by this why
is she saying that as john is saying he
doesn't want to father a bastard could
it be because g-great was already
pregnant and Jon did not know maybe or
it could even have something to do with
John himself John doesn't want a father
a bastard because he is the bastard and
he knows how he's been treated and this
could be another hint that John isn't
actually a bastard he just doesn't know
it yet hence you know nothing Jon Snow
they stream could also be foreshadowing
Egrets death after she whispers you know
nothing Jon Snow her skin starts
dissolving in the hot water her flesh
starts coming off of her bones until
only her skull and skeleton remained in
the pool bubbled thicken red in the very
next chapter is when Yaeger dies in
John's arms and our very last words to
John are you know nothing Jon Snow what
would make ye Gertz death even more
tragic as if she was actually pregnant
with John's child at the time as with
most of the romances in A Song of Ice
and Fire John's relationship with the
eager it is critical to his arc his
experience with her helped shape his
future actions and decisions as Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch but none
of this actually means eager was
pregnant and now that she is dead we may
never find out one way or the other if
she did happen to be pregnant I doubt
anyone would have even noticed any signs
that would indicate she was carrying a
child from the time they met to the time
she died maybe only a few months had
passed and she was usually bundled up in
pretty heavy furs considering the
conditions they were living in so unless
he Girt would have went to visit a woods
wage to get some moon tea she would have
been the only one to know the truth of
it and if she was keeping this a secret
it has now died with her I don't really
see this ever having any impact on the
story at this pole
but I wanted to talk about it
nonetheless I'm always talking about
John and Danny in my videos so this was
kind of nice to revisit John's time
spent with eager let me know what you
think about this idea do you think
Ygritte could have been pregnant put
your thoughts down below in the comment
section I want to thank everyone for
watching today's video I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
everyone on patreon for supporting the
channel I hope you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you